OpenClaw is the fastest growing
open-source AI project of all time. And
somehow, even with all that hype behind
it, there is not a single good guide
that shows you how to properly set up
this thing in the cloud and connect the
one tool you need to actually turn it
into a proper AI assistant, and that's
your Google account. But we need to do
better than just give it access to your
email, your drive, and your calendar. We
need to do it in a secure fashion that
makes sure if anything goes wrong, we
didn't just give the keys to the entire
kingdom to a bad actor. Now, be warned.
Connecting OpenClaw to your Google
Workspace is a giant pain in the butt,
which is why all these AI influencers
skip this step entirely when they show
you how to set up OpenClaw. But I am
going to show you everything in this
video so we can navigate all these weird
technical hurdles that are in front of
us and getting OpenClaw actually up and
running. And at the end of this video,
you'll also get my take on OpenClaw at
large and where I think this thing can
actually provide some value admits all
this wild hype. So, let's first talk
about the hosting options very quickly.
Three big options for where OpenClaw can
live. Number one, and this is what you
see all over the place, is a Mac Mini.
This is expensive, right? This is going
to run you $400 to $600, but you can
connect it to your Mac and it's going to
be up and running all the time. Your
second option is to host it somewhere on
the cloud. So you're paying some third
party say hosting your $7 to $10 a
month. Again, very cheap to essentially
give you space on one of their servers,
which is where OpenCloud will live.
Third option is to host it directly on
your computer. So it's not in the cloud,
it's also not on your Mac Mini, it's
right on your machine. Now, the downside
with having it right on your machine is
if you want OpenClaw running all the
time, well then your machine needs to be
running all the time, which for most
people that's just not the case. And in
today's video, what we're going to focus
on is the third-party option, actually
hosting it on a VPS. And that's because
this is something everyone can do,
right? Whether you're on Linux or
Windows or a Mac, everyone can do this,
right? So, I think this is going to be
the easiest option for most people. This
doesn't require you to shell out money
for a mini. also doesn't require you to
necessarily be on a Mac and it's
probably the most safe option as well.
For today's demo, I'm going to be using
Hostinger as the cloud provider. Three
reasons for that. First one is just the
bang for the buck, right? Seven bucks a
month and I get plenty of power. Number
two is it does give us a one-click
install option with OpenClaw that I'm
going to show you. And then third, once
we're actually on that cloud server, we
can get root access, which is important
when we're setting up things like Gogg
to actually get our Google
authentication working. As for which
plane you should use, KVM2 is plenty of
power. You can get away with KVM1 as
well. Now, once we're here, the biggest
thing you need to pay attention to is
which operating system you're going to
use. We going to use Ubuntu, and you're
going to do 24.04
LTS. So, make sure you confirm this.
From there, you're just going to hit
continue and go through the payment
process. Now, you may see some links or
options about automatically deploying
OpenClaw on your server. I suggest not
selecting that, especially if you're
following this video, because I'm going
to show you instead how to go in the
terminal and install this manually. We
want to do that so we can actually give
OpenClaw root access to this server
we're creating in the cloud. It's going
to be easier for us to install GOG,
which will make it easier for us to
actually get the Google credentials up
and running on our claw agent. Now,
during your setup process, it will ask
you for a root password. Make sure you
remember this root password because we
will be using it when we start working
in the terminal. Now, once you finish up
the setup, you're going to see a page
that looks like this. And what I want
you to pay attention to is this, the
root access. This command right here is
what we're going to take into our own
terminal to SSH into our cloud server.
Now, what is SSH? What does that mean?
Well, it's like using our terminal to
then control the terminal for OpenClaw.
That's all we're essentially doing. Now,
we do have a terminal up here inside of
Hostinger, but it's kind of cumbersome
to every time we want to use the
terminal here to open up Hostinger, go
to this page, turn up this terminal.
Like, I'd rather just do it on my
terminal, right? And it's very simple to
do. So, what I want you to do is to copy
this and then bring up your own
terminal. So, once you're inside your
terminal, just paste that in there. It's
going to ask you this question. Hit yes.
Put in your root password that you just
set. And there you go. It should now say
root at your actual VPS address. Now
it's time to actually install OpenClaw.
Now some people might say, "Hey, do we
really want to do this as the root
user?" Ultimately, this VPS out in the
cloud, all it's doing is OpenClaw. So I
don't really see it as a security issue,
seeing as this is the only thing on
there. This isn't our personal computer
that we're running as root installing
OpenClaw. Now it's time to install
OpenClaw. So if you head to OpenClaw.ai,
scroll down to quick start, it will give
us the command we need to use. Now it's
going to start on Windows. is we want
this to be on MacOSS/ Linux. We're going
to copy this.
Head back to our terminal. Paste this in
there. And it's going to start
installing. Yes, we understand it's
risky. When it asks for what onboarding
mode, do quick start. Here's where it's
going to ask for your model/ provider.
Now, understand a lot of people suggest
anthropic.
Anthropic is expensive, right?
Everything that OpenCloud does is on a
token basis and it can be rather
tokenheavy. So your cost can rack up
pretty quickly and Anthropic I don't
think is necessarily the best tool for
the job unless you have no problem
spending a bunch of money on tokens. My
suggestion is using something a little
bit cheaper. Maybe start with like an
OpenAI model, maybe like a mini model
because you can always go back and
change this, right? You can always
change what models are available to you.
So for me, I'm going to use OpenAI. If
you don't know how to find your API key
for any one of these, guess what? Just
ask AI. It'll walk you through it. Next,
it's going to ask the channel. This is
what messaging app you want to use to
actually talk with Open Claw. Now, I
suggest using Telegram unless you have a
preference for the others because
Telegram's super easy to set up and it's
free. So, to get your Telegram bot
token, what you're going to do is you're
going to open Telegram and you're going
to start a conversation with the bot
father. From there, it's going to ask
you a series of questions, namely, what
do you want to name your bot? And then
it's going to give you a token. It's
going to say, "Use this token to access
the HTTP API." You're going to copy that
token and you're going to paste it in
here. It's going to ask if you want to
configure skills. Now, we can say yes.
Go homebrew install command. No. Now,
this is asking you what skills you want
to install right off the bat. Now, since
we're on a VPS and we're not on a Mac
OS, we're not going to be able to
install a lot of these right away until
we install some dependencies on our
actual server. But, one we can install
right away is Claw Hub. So, you can just
select that one and then hit enter. No.
No. If you want to, you can set these up
right now if you want to. You can always
do them later. It's very simple. And
it's going to ask if you want to enable
hooks. And you can select all three of
these and hit enter. Now it's going to
ask where do we want to hatch our bot.
We're going to hatch in the T UI. We're
really not going to mess with the web UI
very much today. And with that, Clawbot
is now installed on our VPS. First
things it's going to ask you is like, do
you want to give me a name or any sort
of like personality type instructions?
Go ahead and do that now. And then what
we'll do is we'll connect it to Telegram
so we can talk to it there. Now, to get
your bot working inside of Telegram,
just click the link that botfather gave
you to start that conversation. It'll
bring you to a new window. You may see
something at the bottom that says hit
like start to start the bot. But all you
have to do is message it. So, just say
hi. And you'll get a response that looks
like this. Go ahead and just copy that
entire message. Dump it into OpenClaw
and say, "Hey, I'm trying to set up
Telegram. Here's the message I just
got." And it's that easy to set it up.
Now, I can open up Telegram and say,
"How's it going?" And I'll then get a
response inside of Telegram. You can
also see that that response is mirrored
inside of the terminal. But now I no
longer need to talk to OpenClaw inside
of the terminal. I can do everything
inside of Telegram or Slack or WhatsApp
or whatever it is I configured. And
really the great value in OpenClaw I
think is what you just saw there how
easy it is to connect it to different
things. Right? All I did was I spoke to
it, right? Compare that with like an
automation where we would create it with
a personal assistant. I'd have to go in
there and I'd have to create the module
to have to set up the credentials. Here
with OpenClaw, a lot of that's kind of
abstracted away. I just need to speak to
it. So, OpenClaw is now installed on the
VPS. We can talk to it through Telegram.
Now comes the fun part, actually hooking
it up to Google. Now, this is sort of a
multi-step process to do this. First,
we're going to head to Google Workspace.
We're going to give our agent its own
email. We're going to connect it to the
appropriate APIs. Then, we're going to
come back to our VPS, hop into the
terminal. We're going to install the
Gogg CLI. Go. This is the tool that
allows OpenClaw and Google to actually
communicate because unfortunately it is
it isn't as easy as it was with Telegram
where we can just talk to OpenClaw and
have it do itself. After we do that,
we're going to authenticate all of our
accounts and then we'll test it out and
see if it's actually working as it
should. So, a lot of moving parts, but
we're going to go through it step by
step so you can follow along. So, the
first thing we're going to do is we're
going to head to Gmail and we're going
to create a new email for our agent.
Now, this is a level of separation
that's meant to introduce some safety,
right? If I want Open Claw to send
emails, I don't want it to do it with my
email address, right? I don't
necessarily want my name and everything
in my account just at its fingertips.
Also, by having its own email and having
its own accounts, it can still interact
with us, right? It can still take a look
at our calendar. I can add it to the
calendar. I can still give it access to
my Google Drive. I can specify specific
folders, right? This is the idea of
least privilege, right? I don't want to
give it everything because it might want
to use it. We're going to start small.
Now, the one caveat to this is, hey,
what if I do want it to look at my
inbox? Well, that can be kind of
complicated. And you can indeed give it
access to your account if that's what
you want to do. Just go into these
decisions like that with your eyes wide
open and understanding what's at risk
because we don't have to risk everything
if we don't want to. So, go ahead,
create the account and we'll move on to
the next step, which is the workspace.
Now, I've said workspace like 900 times,
but what I'm really talking about is we
now need to move to the Google Cloud.
So, it's console.cloud.google.
Again, I'll put a link down below. What
you need to make sure is that you're on
your agents email account. So, if you
come up here to the top right,
make sure that the account it's
associated with is the bots account.
It's not yours. If you need to switch
it, just click on the name and switch
accounts. Next, I want you to create a
new project. So, click my first project
up here. Do new project. Call it
whatever you want. I'm going to call
mine test one. Call it open cloth.
Doesn't really matter. Now, after you
create that new project, you need to
switch to it. It won't automatically do
that. And once you're switched to it,
it'll show it right here. Now, it's time
to enable all the APIs. So, click this
menu over here on the left. Go to APIs
and services, enabled APIs and services.
And then we're just going to go down the
list. So, you can either go down the
list here or you can just do it in the
search bar. So, for example, search for
Gmail. You'll see Gmail API.
Enable it. Once it's enabled, now I'm
going to want to do something like the
Drive API, Google Drive API. And we're
just going to repeat this process for
all the APIs you want or need. Google
has a billion of them. At the very
least, I suggest doing Google Drive,
Google Calendar, and Gmail. And once
you've enabled all the APIs you want, go
to the OOTH consent screen on the left
hand side. You'll see a page like this
and hit get started. For your app name,
call whatever you want. Use an email
that you have access to. Hit next. For
audience, we're going to do external.
Contact information. Again, just put
whatever email you want
and create. Next, go to audience
and I'm going to want you go to publish
app, hit confirm, and you're all set
there. Next, go back to the navigation
menu, the three bars on the left. Go to
APIs and services, and go to
credentials. Go to create credentials
over here and do OOTH client ID.
Application type, we're going to do
desktop app. Call it whatever you want
and hit create. Now take note of your
client ID and client secret. Copy those,
put them somewhere secure because you
won't see them again. But what you also
need to do is you need to download the
JSON. Once you downloaded the JSON and
you recorded the ID and secret, you can
hit okay. Now what we need to do is we
need to take that JSON file and we need
to put it inside our VPS that has all of
our credentials and that's what OpenClaw
is going to be able to use to actually
connect our Google accounts. So for this
next step, we need to be in the
terminal. So open up a new terminal
window and paste in this command. Now
what are we doing here? This is us
taking our downloaded JSON file and
copying it onto our VPS. So I'm going to
give you this command, but you're going
to have to change some stuff, right?
What are you going to have to change?
This whole blue part you're going to
need to change because this blue
section, that is my downloaded path to
that JSON file we just got from Google.
Okay. How do you find that path? Just
right click on the file inside your
download folder and do copy as path.
Also, you'll need to change this. Right?
This is my VPS servers IP. Yours will be
different. If you're confused of how to
change these things, just copy this
command that I'm giving you. Bring it to
AI. Explain what you're trying to do. It
will adjust it for you. That's my best
advice. It's going to ask for your root
password when you do that. And then it's
just going to copy it over. Now, at this
point, we do want to SSH back into our
VPS. So go ahead, head to hostinger and
grab that command. And let's just
confirm that our file is actually there.
So we can see here that the file does
exist and was copied over. Now it's time
to actually install GOG. So you're just
going to paste in all these commands
which are again in the school. And
you're going to let it go to work for a
couple minutes. Now at the end of all
that, you should see something that
looks like this where it's like
v0.9.0.5.
Basically, you can just run go space-
version. And if you get something that
shows an actual version, well, hey,
congratulations. Gogg is now installed.
So go ahead and clear this out. So we've
now installed Gogg. Now we need to
authenticate our credentials with Gogg.
So this is our next command. And this is
by far the most confusing and
challenging part of this entire setup.
And it's where everybody gets lost. So
this command looks simple enough, right?
Google off add. And you're going to put
your particular email. The services
you're going to put here. The one inside
the school will include additional
services. Trim this down to whatever
APIs you actually enabled. For me, it
was Gmail, Calendar, and Drive. When I
run this command, it's going to return a
gigantic link. I need to follow that
link to authenticate my account. Problem
is, we're on this VPS. When I follow
that link, it's not it's going to bring
up the browser on my computer, which
means it won't work. So, to get it to
work, we need to essentially route it in
a different direction to our computer.
So, to do that, you need to create a
second terminal window right on your
local computer. And there is a specific
command you're going to need to give it.
That command depends
on the giant link we get here. So I
can't tell you what exactly it's going
to look like. You have to pick out a a
series of numbers in that giant link. To
make this easy, what you're going to do
is you're going to have another window
open with a large language model. In
this case, it's clawed. It doesn't
matter what it is, but you're going to
have this prompt in there. It says I'm
setting up open claw on oinger. My VPS
is this IP again. Where do you get this
on this page IP right here?
I just ran a go off ad command and got
the URL with a port number. I'm going to
paste the output. Give me the exact ssh
tunnel command I need to run on my local
computer with the correct port number
filled in. What does that mean? Doesn't
matter. It's going to give you a command
that you need to copy and paste into the
second window. confused? Totally okay.
Just watch me do this and you're going
to repeat it. So, we're going to hit
enter. Giant URL. We copy the URL.
We paste the URL in here.
It gives me the command. Copy.
Go into the other terminal. Paste.
Enter password.
Now click the browser.
Now choose your account
advanced.
Go to OC1. It's totally okay. Hit
continue. Select all. Continue.
Authorized.
All right.
A lot of moving parts. That link doesn't
stay up forever. So, if it expires,
you're going to have to do that again.
But that's the series of events you need
to do. Okay. Hit enter. Copy the link.
Go to AI. Paste the link. Copy command.
Second terminal again on the local
level. Paste in that command. Enter root
password. Go back. Follow link. Next.
Next. Next. Next. Confused? Great. Once
you do that though, you're connected.
You're set up. It's then going to ask
for a passphrase. You can use any
passphrase you want. And once you do
that, you should then see your email pop
up for your bot with the services that
are provided. Now, if you wanted to add
more services, let's say later you
wanted to add sheets or slides or
something. You would just repeat that
process we just did. You don't need to
do the whole JSON thing. You just need
to do the last round of commands we did,
right? Where you do the URL, you do this
whole double terminal thing. Painful,
but that's it. anytime you want to add
commands, add services, that's how you
would do it. So after we create that key
ring password, we want to set that in
ourv file so we're not always being
asked for it every time we need to use
these Google resources. So we're going
to run this command which is going to
open up nano. It's going to take you to
something that looks like this. We just
want to hit the down arrow once. Go
ahead and type go_key
password
equal sign and then you're just going to
put in your keyring password. Once you
put in your password to exit to save and
exit this, you're going to do control O
enter and then control X. After you do
that, we're going to run chmod 600 on
this to lock it down. Now, after we run
chmod, then we're going to run this
final command. And that's going to make
sure we aren't constantly asked for the
keyring password when we're using
Google. And at this point, everything
should be connected. So, let's run it
through one final test inside the
terminal to make sure we didn't miss
anything. So, this is the command we're
going to run again. Switch that email
with your email. And you should get a
bunch of stuff that looks like this.
Essentially, it should be checking the
email and all those other things to see
if it actually got any hits back. If it
asks you for like your key ring again,
that means you missed something in the
EMV file and you probably need to go
back the last couple minutes and just
make sure you pasted all the commands
in. And also, if you don't get your
answer from there, just make sure you're
copying and pasting this into your AI of
choice and being like, hey, like what's
going wrong here? Now, if everything in
that last step worked for you, as it did
for me, now there's one more thing we
need to do while we're still inside the
terminal. And we essentially now have to
give OpenClaw access to that Google
keyring. And to do that, we're going to
have to hop into Nano again. So, we're
going to run this command. Once inside
nano, you're going to go down to where
it says services,
and we're going to create a new
environmental variable essentially. So,
we'll do environment
equals
Then just like we did before, go hearing
password equals and then you're going to
put your password in there again and
then control O entertrl + x. Next, we
need to restart the system. So we're
going to put in these two commands. And
now openclaw should finally be ready to
go. So now let's actually test it out.
So I told OpenClaw Gogg and your Google
accounts are set up. Send an email to me
at my email. I gave him my email saying
what's up and send a calendar invite for
2 p.m. tomorrow and let's have a chat.
and it came back and told me well what
time zone how long. Um so we'll tell it
told it hey use CST 30 minutes primary
calendar use a link and get creative now
all these sorts of things like these
default settings that it's asking for.
You can actually just have back and
forth with open claw and just say hey
going forward remember it's always CST
remember this is my email because
remember again it essentially has like a
pretty robust rag system under the hood
as well as a bunch of markdown files to
both remember its chats and remember
specific essentially character traits
that you give it. So, it says it sent
the email. So, let's see if it actually
did it. All right. So, I got the email
from my bot saying what's up. And I also
got the calendar invite. Pretty sweet.
Now, speaking of calendars, what you can
also do at this point is you can go into
your personal calendars and you can
invite OpenClaw and whatever email
address you get it to be able to view
your calendar. So, when you start
talking to your bot, in my case, Maya,
and I say, "Hey, take a look at my
calendar tomorrow and see what times are
available." It can actually do that,
right? Right? And those are the sort of
ways that you can essentially give it
access to say your calendar. It can view
it, but you're not giving it necessarily
like root access to your calendar,
right? It can't edit events and stuff,
but it can still take a look and adjust
things as needed. That's the nice thing
with giving it its email because, hey,
it can still add things to your calendar
via invites versus again having full
access to your complete digital life and
changing things on the spot. So, this is
where we're going to wrap up for today.
Like you saw, it's actually kind of
painful to get Google set up with
OpenClaw. Even though it's a very
intuitive tool and once it is up and
running, it's very easy to add things to
it. Google is one of the exceptions,
which kind of sucks because having
access to the email, the calendar, and
all these things is really, really
important if we truly want to turn this
into an AI assistant that's actually
useful. And in terms of usefulness and
about all the hype with Claudebot,
just understand what this is and what it
isn't. What it is is a very intuitive,
very powerful personal assistant. But
truth be told, a lot of things that it
can do are things that if you stripped
away and just did in a vacuum, like
specific automations and cron jobs and
scheduling things, you've been able to
do inn and other places for a long long
time. I think the real value with open
claw is the manner in which it's been
packaged and the foundation it's laying
for what can be built upon it in the
next year or two. right now in its
current iteration. Again, very useful.
But the things it's actually doing
aren't particularly novel, nor are they
things that we couldn't do before. It's
just all in one place now, and we can
talk to it on Telegram, which also we
could do before as well. But all that to
say, I'm not trying to like knock
OpenClaw. It's an awesome tool. Just is
it, you know, is it necessarily new what
it's doing? No. But it's packaged in a
very special way, which is really what I
think the discussion should be about
because that's where the real value
lies. The real value isn't telling it
to, you know, send me an email, although
that is important if an AI assistant is
what you want. So, as always, let me
know what you thought in the comments
and you can stay on the lookout for more
OpenClaw videos, right? Hopefully, this
has sort of laid the foundation so we
can actually start doing cool stuff with
it. And as always, I'll see you